i was taking my mom to work in the  morning we left the house about 7 45 i  got behind a  light blue  um  camry toyota i was stopped right behind  her  and when the light turned green  um  she didn't move it looked like she was  looking down  and  so i waited a couple seconds and then  she still didn't proceed so i beeped at  her  and she  she started moving really slow so i  try to change lanes so i try to change  to the to the left lane the middle lane  and she followed me and she kept cutting  me off so every time i tried changing  land lanes she she went with me and  wouldn't let me pass her and she  wouldn't she wouldn't proceed any  further and so i looked over and i saw i  saw her and  we kept going  and then that's where you could hear  that she she shot into the vehicle  [Music]  you